and it's directed by Damien chazelle for
La La Land but I mean he really goes for
it these enormous set pieces it opens
with this mad Hollywood party yeah like
in real life how long were you at that
party for oh that's you crowd surfing
that is it was yeah it must be crowds of
you okay so fun so we get why it's
called Babylon now right clearly this is
like the G-rated version of that part I
mean the party is insane Damien I mean
he's such a Visionary kind of director
but there's an amazing extraordinary one
in that party scene where you kind of
meet all the different characters and
it's a huge ensemble cast you've got
Brad Pitt and Diego and you know Gene
Smart and you've got a chicken stealing
someone's cocaine and running up you
know like stunts you've got someone
falling from the ceiling so this is all
being timed with like this crane
movement we're not shooting in studio
we're shooting like on location so it's
even more difficult but so much is
happening
um and and you kind of get a glimpse of
everything it's the kind of movie where
you have to see it on a big screen
because there's so so much happening in
the frame yeah at every single moment
you could look anywhere and you're
seeing a whole you know this whole
tapestry of Madness
um but doing those one is and knowing
that you don't want to be the person
that makes you go again yeah it's also
how did you cope and keeping that thing
on your breasts oh yeah that's what I
think I'm watching that going is that
going to stay on I mean that's what that
is assuming fee there was a lot of yeah
slips but that I am like even in that
scarf thing that we're calling a dress I
am still probably the most clothed
person
so honestly I but we were also
desensitized to nudity very quickly that
it in that scene there's literally like
orgies happening behind us while people
are talking I mean they're so so a guy
jumping on the penis was kind of one of
myself
sadly that isn't the clip we have
[Music]